Can you sing something for us in touch
on that is that is the scariest thing.
That's only sing for me on my birthday.
Your birthday.
Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Birthday to
right.
Okay.
We met at a photo shoot where I had to
get covered and pepto Bismol it would end
up looking like I was wearing a suit
of pink paint, but paint is toxic,
so we use pepto Bismol instead.
So what
we met at a photo shoot,
I was in a suit with a gun and then
she was covered in Pepto Bismol.
I was trying to be a gentleman
and just like, you know,
keep my eyes up here and not make her
feel uncomfortable for the photo shoot and
stuff like that.
So I was just trying to,
to pick her brains and ask her what
she was into and Futurama Star Trek.
And then she had the doctor who, and I
was like, oh man. Okay. She has a nerd.
All right,
we'll get along.
MMM.
I have a tendency to be too nice and get
walked over. And he made sure that I,
that that doesn't happen and
that I stand up for myself.
And he's also just always himself and
never feels the need to be anybody else.
I love you because you're
one of the sweetest,
nicest people I've ever met in my life.
I mean,
you're nice to people I don't think
deserve to be nice to, you know, to, um,
when I'm emotional and thrown a fit or
just being over the top about something,
you're always there to the
center mean you're just,
you're that little piece of me that I
didn't realize I needed until I met you.
Okay.
I don't know if that's everything
I was supposed to say or not.
It's a lot easier when she's not
listening. Who said I love you first
she did by accident. Um, but I
was leaving for work. He was,
walked me to the door and was saying by
why left for work and then he asked for
when I was like, okay, well I love
you, bye. And then close the door.
And we both realized like I was on one
side of the door and he was on the other
and we both realize that it's the
first time you said it. And I was like,
what if he didn't mean to say that
I don't want to embarrass him.
So I like started walking
to my car and I'm like,
but if he did realize it now I feel
so weird is I'm going to run back up.
So I ran back up to my apartment all the
way up the stairs and then ran up and I
was like, did you just say I love you?
And he's like, yes, I did by accident.
I was like, well I love you
too. And then it all worked out.
She was on her way to work and I stay
in at her place just kind of like
accidentally. I was like,
all right, I love you, bye.
And then she left and then like
as soon as she shut the door,
I remember being like, oh Geez, why don't
I do that? That was going to be weird.
But then yeah,
just like a movie,
she came running right back in and just
kiss me real passionately and Israel
sweet and made me feel
better about everything.
So
putting on her seatbelt,
I uh, I think she gets caught
up in her own head though.
I think that's her biggest
struggle is just, you know,
wanting to make sure everybody's happy
around her and that everybody is treated
fairly.
So she gets kind of in her head too much
and then I have to let her know that
she's doing okay.
Did you talk about my theme?
So off.
Okay.
Um,
hey bitch.
Maddix sometimes he just agrees with me
even though he has no idea what we're
saying.
I kept trying to make plans and nothing
was ever going to seem good enough and I
was just going to keep postponing it
until something was perfect. So I finally,
me being the jerk I am and having
a really bad sense of humor,
I thought April fools would be the
best day to do it. So I was like,
you know what? This has to happen.
This is a beautiful day for it.
If we posted it online,
which we didn't. So anyways,
we go up to this place called [inaudible].
I had previously gotten our dog Ava,
a little dog tag that just said,
do you want to watch cartoons with me?
You know,
cause that's one of our big things is we
watch cartoons and we're big geeks and
we get to mountain now and I tell her
to take a look at the new dog tag.
So you're saying, do you want to
watch cartoons with me? And I go,
well yeah know I'm bent over on one.
He was like, yeah, for forever with me.
And you know, she said yes. And
it was, it was pretty amazing.
He picked me up.
He had just gotten like a nicer button
down that I didn't recognize. He's like,
Oh yeah, just bought this today. I was
like, Oh nice. We go home. And he's like,
well I kinda had a plan for us today. I
hope that's okay. And I was like, okay.
He said we were going hiking, but he
was wearing his nicer new button down.
I was like, are you sure you want to
wear that? Hiking, and he's like, oh,
it'll be fine. I was
like, something's strange.
And then it goes to hug me in his heart
beating super fast. And I was like,
I think he's going to propose today.
He asked me to look at our dog's collar
and I immediately knew. I'm like,
that's a very reared request.
I think something very
specific is about to happen.
He put a a a dog tag on our,
our dog's collar, uh, that said
one to watch cartoons with me.
And so I look at him and I'm like, wait,
what? And then he's like, I'm sorry.
I wanted something
specific that I can say,
do you want to watch
cartoons with me forever?
And then got down on one knee and
proposed with his grandmother's ring.
And it was very cute.
He is my support in every single way.
And uh, he makes me
happy. He makes me laugh.
He makes me take life a little
less seriously. So I think without,
I would just be lost completely
for the short version
and devastated. No, what
I would do without you,
man. I'm trying not to
use bad words, but man,
it'd be scary not to have
you that wild to think about.
I don't like thinking about it.
Okay,
man, you're making me sound like the
Ice Queen, but I love you very much.
Okay.
We actually scripted that. Yeah, abuse.
I appreciate it guys. You're all
doing it. Awesome. Thank you guys.
I hope we were abuse. I
don't know about you, man.
I feel pretty lonely right
now after watching that
video forever alone together,
my fellow sense, it's out there. Join
our cluster of being forever. Last July.
No cluster shined alone.
My close to
subscribe up here. Don't
forget to subscribe and we
got more videos down here.
Always go
onward and upward.
[inaudible] we've got another
video coming out a couple of days,
so check out for that one.
There we go.